in the story of virgin mary right when
jesus was born and we read the bible in
your mind based on the bible that you
read and you studied
did she say i was not with anybody i'm a
virgin i've never been with a man
and then the story came about meaning
what is the sequencing in your uh ideas
because yes a lot of people at that time
can claim and say look i didn't get
pregnant i'm telling you i didn't do it
i don't have sex with anybody it was a
guy that came and i'm pregnant the
question would be
what are the chances of her saying that
and her son being
jesus christ
that's a mathematical question that's
more statistically you know the chances
of her saying yeah i'm telling you i
wasn't with anybody this is god's work
like okay mary you know you're full of
it you have no idea what you're talking
about i'm telling you this is not me and
then boom
one point one out of 113 billion people
being born her kid becomes jesus what's
it so what's that it can't become okay
see these are in my mind two independent
uh events they're they're not
necessarily tied together
we don't know we don't we you know
people that study ancient roman gods uh
you know can list off some of these
names that are not at the top of my head
but uh but there was another one um uh
let's see um oh shoot of tyanna
forget his name 2500 2500 years before
it happened to jesus there's another
story like that well no no around the
same time actually uh at the same
century um and uh anyway his name is
escaping me now but but but uh but there
were lots of individuals like this who
claimed that they were born of a virgin
uh were persecuted by authorities were
put to death were raised you know from
the dead and went to heaven and so on
the jesus story is not the only one so
you can't put a calculation on it and
then and then combine these two
independent events the virgin birth and
but the difference is jesus you know one
of them and you can't think of the other
person's name
but others there's lots of them there's
a lot what i'm saying to you is no no
what i'm saying i know you say there's a
lot of my skeptic side i'm more skeptic
than i'm a believer
i'm more on the skeptical side on the
believer's side but i'm also a math guy
what is the likelihood of a person
saying that and the son
ends up becoming who he is and has two
billion people
fought on this guy well again these are
independent uh events
jesus didn't become jesus because of the
virgin birth or anything like that it's
because of paul
and even there
you have to really trace for about two
centuries how christianity became the
uh the the state religion under
constantine in the fourth century uh
fifth
no late fourth century
and uh
and and and and you only need like a one
and a half two percent uh conversion
rate or birth rate it within a religion
for it to grow from you know a few tens
of people to a few tens of millions of
people to a few hundred million people
by the fifth century all the way up till
today to two billion people that's like
compound interest so it doesn't take a
miracle to explain the growth of
religion same thing
you can't see the same thing but the
argument you're making could be made for
islam
one of the chances that mohammed in the
seventh century
and his particular unique story would
end up
you know in the 21st century with a
billion and a half followers no no but
that's not what i'm saying no no that's
not what i'm no no there's two by the
way if you want to do that map then we
have to go back to hindu which i think
is 2300 bc and then
buddhism that's 2500 bc how come they're
both smaller than muslim and
christianity then the debate becomes
well then if that's the case muslim is
creating more momentum than any other
religion in the world so we can have
that discussion i've done that as well
because yeah that's completely separate
where i'm going with you is the final
one
i'm going to
a guy gets up and he says
here's who i am this is what's going to
happen a woman is pregnant
she says i'm telling you i didn't hook
up with anybody like what are you
talking about
of course you're going to claim
something like that you're out of your
mind i'm telling you this is not i don't
do anything i'm a virgin whatever i
don't know what's going on this could be
something special here
years lady we find out it's jesus and
the chances of that to be 2 billion
people you can't say well it's that easy
any religion could do it as long as they
grow one and a half percent of weekend
well but that's the hindsight bias
you're taking the one that that won out
and ignoring all the other ones that uh
that didn't become major all i'm saying
is
it's the chances of a virgin mother
and she makes the claim then the son
becomes who she said he was going to
become that's a very
that's a very uh
it's a little bit spooky if i can use
the word because even as a skeptic
myself you sit there and say what are
the chances of that so i'm not going to
what prophet muhammad said i'm not going
to what anybody else and i'm
specifically used in that situation we
don't have any other story like that
that got as big as this one did
well but again you're you're picking out
the the hindsight bias you're picking
out the one that happened to uh be
successful you have to look at all the
ones that have the same story that
didn't become successful why didn't they
you see so so maybe so that's a question
for you though not for me here it is i i
found it i was looking at my slides here
apollonius of tyanna he's a first
century a.d living in asia minor his
followers claimed he was the son of god
that he was able to walk through closed
doors heal the sick cast out demons and
raise the dead girl back to life he was
accused of witchcraft sent to rome
before the court was jailed but escaped
after he died his followers claimed he
appeared to them and then ascended to
heaven
so
now this is around the same time as
jesus and jesus didn't become a big
thing until again centuries later you
know the gospels themselves were not
even written for the earliest one mark
was 40 years after jesus death the
others 50 60 70 90 years
and uh and i'll just give you some other
examples here virgin birth myths um
these these are deities who were born of
a virgin dionysus perseus buddha attus
krishna horus mercury romulus and jesus
dionysius is the ancient greek god said
to have been born from a virgin woman
fathered by the king of heaven to have
transformed water into wine introduced
the idea of eating and drinking the
flesh and blood of god
was the liberator of his people and to
have returned from the dead uh
resurrection myths the egyptian god of
life death and fertility was osiris so
this is 2400 bce that appears in the
first pyramid text
he was he was considered to be the giver
of life in this world the redeemer and
merciful judge of the dead in the next
world
egyptian kings believed that as osiris
rose from the dead so would they in
union with him inheriting eternal life
and by the new kingdom everyone believed
that if they accepted osiris as their
god they too would be resurrected which
one of them has two million two billion
people well so there you're making an
argument for uh you know populist
argument that you know whoever whoever
has the most adherence is more likely to
be right so christianity about one and a
half times more likely than israel i
know i simply give it a point i know i
simply get are you a sports guy or no
are you a person
i'm a big sports guy okay which one tell
me which sport oh i i follow the you
know nfl and nba all that's pretty good
so let's go so that's the nba okay let's
go nba who's the greatest basketball
player of all time
well it's gotta be kareem
you go so you say kareem okay
but i'll go with michael jordan too okay
but i think you you make it interesting
if you keep it kareem right okay
give me your top five so let's just say
kareem and michael are top two who's the
other three who's the other well well if
we're going with pre uh current players
because lebron obviously has to be on
the list okay let's look on there as
well so you got two okay lebron yeah
okay so and i guess i would put magic
johnson okay
you know great player and also
charismatic and and you know change the
game
um and uh probably larry bird just to
throw in you know one white guy
well it's good to know you don't
discriminate i respect you
so now let's go with that now you said
kareem tell me why korean because i
think kareem is a very easy argument as
the greatest of all time but what's your
argument for korean being the greatest
of all time well because the top top
scorer of all time and also
championships and and you know
a true motivated leader of his teams
and he'd dominate a game you know
college nba
you know revolutionary type of a player
he couldn't be consistent yeah number of
mvps number of these things that he did
okay
so all i'm saying to you is i'm not
saying
that single event is the reason why
kareem abdul-jabbar is agreeing you know
how they say michael jordan's the
greatest of all time because he went to
six championships and he never lost one
i think that's one point but i don't
think that alone is enough of a catalog
to call him the greatest of all time
right so lebron's been to more
championships then you have to go to
bill russell
but to say
that your mother was a virgin and you
were born and you got two billion
followers i think i get to point i don't
know if that says you are the greatest
of all time
i see i see where you're going with this
yeah no i can't i'm afraid i can't agree
with that because you don't have to
agree with that
we just got to give a point there i
think they're independent variables
there anyway
so now let me give you the point for the
opposite side here's the point for you
for the opposite side
uh
uh oh and i'm going to give you a soft
one here you know just see what you're
going to say about this so
so many people that are educated that
have degrees smart folks you mentioned
paul earlier oh jesus became big because
of apostle paul he was a pretty big
skeptic and he was saul before he was
paul right so he's a
he wasn't just a lightweight guy and he
was a true believer later on without him
you know him and billy graham probably
compete for who baptized the most people
some say billy some say him it is what
it is what do you say to those who say
michael
super educated people like c.s lewis who
wrote mere christianity oxford
university professor the guy didn't
believe in anything he wrote the
chronicles of narnia then he flips and
he becomes one of the biggest you know
believers of the the religion of
christianity to the point where any
church that baptizes and brings new
members on the first book they read of
cost of discipleship the second book
they read is mere christianity why is an
educated man like
you know c.s lewis later on in life that
you're supposed to get smarter the
smarter he got the more he flipped why
and you studied c.s lewis why yes yes
yes well again these are in in
individual cases everyone's different i
mentioned um
earlier the language of god francis
collins story and uh
yeah c.s lewis is similar and in fact
francis collins cites c.s lewis as an
example because he was obviously such a
smart guy
frankly amongst the theologians that is
really serious super professional
theologians that you know they don't
think c.s lewis is all that serious as a
theologian even though they share their
beliefs not that i'm uh
able to make that assessment but uh just
for what that's worth okay why i don't
know you know he um he wrote a beautiful
book called the grief observed about his
wife who died of cancer again
you know he grapples with the problem of
evil the odyssey did you ever see the
movie did you see yeah oh yeah of course
yeah yeah joy was her name right joy
something i think
yeah it was true he died from cancer and
it really questioned his faith
right yes no no it's an incredible so i
think anthony hopkins plays c.s lewis
crushed it yeah i mean yeah and uh
deborah winger plays joy it's it's a
it's a great film
yeah so there again you know i don't
fault anybody for
you know
wanting or needing or desiring religion
or claiming it on some level
for what it's worth one of the leader
top uh
modern skeptics martin gardner he was
one of the founders of the modern
skeptic movement a long time monthly
columnist before me at scientific
american wrote many books about uh
arguments for and against god and he
himself said well i think atheists have
better arguments than the theists do for
god's existence but i believe in god
and it was like what
and he called himself a the deist or a
pragmatist
this is the correct term but the
pragmatist that is there are pragmatic
reasons for believing in god that have
to do with emotion and emotional need
and meaningfulness purposefulness in
life and since you can't prove there is
no god and it's one of a handful of
mysterian mysteries as they're called
like free will and determinism you know
scientists tell us that the universe is
determined from whence comes volition or
free will well i i i feel free so i i'm
i i think of it as a useful fiction you
know and maybe god is like that for some
people and i and i think some i think
it's something like that for c.s lewis
although i don't recall exactly uh it's
been so long since i studied him that
that what his uh reasoning was
personally everyone has a personal story
and so i think probably it was something
along those lines so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you